[Music]
we're only a month and a half into the
new year but there is already concern it
could end up being the warmest on record
that is due in part to a new report from
the National Oceanic and Atmospheric
Administration which says the January we
just lived through featured the warmest
global temperatures since record-keeping
began 141 years ago think about that
here with more on what it means
meteorologist Jeff beard la Jeff good
morning 141 years the warmest on record
plus in 18 years prior to that we've had
the 10 warmest January why well we're
burning a lot of fossil fuels and we're
releasing a lot of carbon dioxide into
the atmosphere that plus the extra water
vapor because we have a warmer
atmosphere it holds more water vapor
when you combine all of that you end up
with warmer temperatures and those will
continue to go up in the United States
so far it has been our warmest year on
record we're likely to finish out one of
our warmest winters on record and in
Russia it was 10 degrees above normal
just during the month of January and
this is all without an El Nino used to
be in order to see your warmest year or
your warmest month you need it in El
Nino apparently we don't need that
anymore yeah it's not just warm but the
acceleration of just how warm it is how
quickly it gets there is the issue isn't
it that's the problem we're not
concerned about how warm it's gonna get
we're concerned about how fast it's
gonna get warm and whether we as a
species and more so plants and animals
can evolve and I can tell you that a lot
of them will not be able to evolve we're
in a sixth mass extinction and we're
expecting that over the next hundred
years we could lose millions more
species on there take a look at this
right here this is a really cool graphic
from Ed Hawkins he's a scientist in the
UK and this is a graphic over the last
2000 years and we're zoomed in now just
to the last hundred years look at how it
turns blood red at the very end so I
don't know guys can you show it again
show the whole 2,000 years and then zoom
back in there of what going from the
blue to to the red yeah but it's not
just warm it's it last year was one of
the wettest years on record - is there a
there's we good yeah it's amazing it was
below normal red is above normal
there is only the warm of the atmosphere
is the more water vapor it holds and the
more
which do we have we had record flooding
last year and by the way we're expecting
more flooding this year Noah just put
out a report saying watch out in the
spring in the Midwest we could see bad
flooding again not as bad as last year
but right now in the southeast we've
seen at least 300 percent of our normal
rainfall since January 1st and we're
gonna see more flooding this upcoming
week with another three to five inches
of rain on the way
we've talked a lot about Antarctica and
the temperatures that we've seen there
the impact from all of that melting ice
on what we have so we've had two records
in the past week we almost hit 70
degrees 70 degrees in Antarctica I'm
planning a beach vacation down there
that is Pine Island glacier which is
right near the Antarctic Peninsula it's
on the west side of Antarctica we're
very worried about that an iceberg just
broke off at six times the size of
Manhattan don't worry that's not gonna
raise sea level however it is
destabilizing the glaciers in West
Antarctica two big ones weights and Pine
Island
if Pine Island would have melt and
collapse and it will eventually maybe a
few decades not tomorrow maybe a few
decades maybe a couple hundred years but
when it does just that glacier alone can
contribute four feet of sea-level rise
and it won't happen over hundreds of
years it would happen within a decade or
two gotta start making changes is
absolutely the message Jeff thank you
welcome
you